il y donc est ce une faillite européenne
ou est ce une responsabilité unique des
gouvernements successifs du berceau de
cette démocratie nous allons nous poser
la question aujourd'hui avec nos invités
depuis plusieurs jours plusieurs mois
c'est une tragédie en cinq actes avec
bon nombre de rebondissements à laquelle
nous assistons et nous allons tenter
d'analyser les raisons de ces blocages
et surtout leurs conséquences
avec moi aujourd'hui benjamin coriatt
économistes bonjour vous êtes membre du
collectif des économistes atterrés
ensuite nous avons genre je privais
lakiss bonjour vous êtes géographe et
géopoliticien à l'université pas rien
merci d'être avec nous pascal durand
député européen membre d'europe écologie
merci enfin philippe dessertine
économistes et vous êtes professeur à
l'iae l'institut administrations les
entreprises c'est ça paris sorbonne
merci également
mais d'abord je me tourne vers vous
olivier toscer c'est vous qui avez
réalisé ce documentaire que vous avez
donc fini en 2013 que nous avions déjà
diffusés à l'époque
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé en fait à
vous intéresser à cette question la
jeunesse de la crise moi ce qui
m'intéressait c'était de montrer de
revenir aux origines du malentendu entre
la grèce et l'europe parce que ce
malentendu il ne va pas de la crise
justement et date du début de l'entrée
des négociations d'entrée de la grèce
dans l'ue dans l'union européenne qui
s'appelait à l'époque de la cee serre
que dès le début de l'histoire entre la
grèce et l'europe été marquée par une
nette est de malentendus halles pour
vous c'est juste un malentendu donc
c'est un malentendu fondamental du fait
que l'europe voulait que la grèce
ressortir la dictature des colonels
entre dans la communauté économique
européenne
parce que c'était l'europe parce qu'elle
s'appelle parce que c'est l'europe et
l'europe c'est quoi ces grecs
non c'est le nom d'une déesse la
mythologie grecque et que les dirigeants
européens de l'époque et en particulier
du scar destin et plein d'autres de ses
collègues en europe étaient des
dirigeants politiques qui était qui
avait été façonné par une culture
classique avait repris le grec allait
vous me dites que valéry giscard
d'estaing est un grand romantique finale
exactement c'est une vision totalement
romantique et donc on peut il fallait la
grèce entre
dans l'union européenne dans la cee
coûte que coûte et le plus vite possible
et c'est pour ça que dès le départ on a
fermé les yeux pour accueillir ce membre
ce nouveau monde qui n'est pas que un
nouveau membre
un nom supplémentaire mais qui est le
berceau de la démocratie et donc ont dès
le début on confond la grèce
d'aujourd'hui et la grèce antique
vous avez eu des difficultés à
recueillir les témoignages qu'on renvoie
vous avez au coeur triche et valéry
giscard d'estaing fin de la plupart des
acteurs de l'époque
vous avez eu des difficultés à les
toucher ils ont voulu ils ont accepté
facilement de parler tout cela et ils
ont accepté après avoir avoir dû leur
expliquer très longuement qu'elle était
lequel était le l'état d'esprit dans
lequel je voulais construire ce film
parce qu'à l'époque déjà en 2013 été
pendant dix huit pains c'était déjà un
des paroxysmes de la crise et donc le
fait que ma démarche était historique a
permis de convaincre justement aussi
bien monsieur juncker que monsieur
giscard d'estaing et jusqu'à destin
notamment était tout à fait prêt parce
qu'il revendique encore son rôle moteur
dans l'entrée de la grèce dans l'europe
tout en se démarquant totalement de
l'entrée de la grèce dans l'euro par
exemple
mais chirac à marcher sur ses pas et on
le voit bien oui et tout le monde tout
donc on dirait quoi qu'il ya une forme
de romantisme chez nono président
français consomment à caen mais vous
n'êtes pas d'accord qu'il ya des
considérations géopolitiques mais
certainement expliquer ça va mieux que
moi mais il ya aussi des considérations
qui sont
plus économique si je peux dire
strictement économique
alors on aura sans doute l'occasion d'en
parler plus en détail mais ma conviction
profonde pour avoir suivi tous ces
événements évidemment de très près comme
comme l'ensemble des gens qui sont ici
j'imagine c'est que il y avait une
volonté très claire au moins de la
france l'est sans doute d'autres pays
que l'euro ne se fasse pas sans des pays
du sud c'est de venir sans la grèce sans
le portugal sont à l'intérieur par le
biais de l'euro oui là on parle de
l'euro mais on ira un drame est alors
bon si c'est bon on revient on reviendra
sur ce point mais ce point est essentiel
et bien sûr on voulait pas d'un face à
face avec le deutsche mark
alors pour le l'entrée de dents dans
dans la communauté économique européenne
proprement dit je pense que la dimension
pays sortant d'une dictature etc et
l'europe ayant vocation à étendre un
espace de démocratie en elle et autour
d'elle a été une dimension non
négligeable et c'est heureux et c'est
heureux pascal durand qu'est ce que vous
en avez pensé de ce documentaire est ce
que bien beaucoup de bien parce que il a
le mérite de d'essayer de remettre en
perspective que je trouve que le défaut
à un des défauts de l'analyse actuelle
que l'on fait de la situation grecque
c'est de ne s'intéresser qu'à la fin et
de ne pas regarder d'où on vient comme
on vient quels ont été les
responsabilités des uns et des autres et
je trouve que ces documentaires explique
notamment les choix économiques le fait
d'avoir volontairement regarder ailleurs
quand quand on imaginait que les comptes
avaient été truqués et par ailleurs qui
a la responsabilité de ces trucages donc
le documentaire là dessus sur cette
question là est très très important
parce qu'il remet en perspective
l'histoire ne manquait finalement en ce
moment des éléments de contexte sur
georges prévu la crise à la lueur de
de ce documentaire fait de ce que vous
en savez et pour ouvrir justement ce
débat vous diriez que c'est une
responsabilité collective quand on parle
là dans ce cadre on dit bien ce
documentaire de l'élite auxerre une
faillite européenne est ce que c'est une
faillite européenne c'est une faillite
grecque
c'est une faillite européenne s'est
aussi je dirais une crise européenne qui
conduit comme toute l'église
les nouveaux amis je pense que les
documentaires est très utile parce que
dès le début de la crise malheureusement
on a traité cette situation d'un strict
point économique jeu on n'est pas
fatigués les publics avec des discours
incompréhensible et caetera et on est
allé à la viande et riz ciel donc donc
c'est très bien de montrer je pense que
dans donc ça ouvre un débat c'est un
débat je pense passionnant pas seulement
pour la grèce ou pas surtout pour la
grèce mais surtout pour l'europe donc
vous pour dit que c'est un malentendu
mais je sais pas si c'est un malentendu
mais enfin c'est une histoire très
ancienne et c'est une stack fondamental
pour l'europe il ya deux choses il ya
d'un côté le thème grecs et ensuite la
grèce en tant qu'etat le thème grec est
fondamental pour l'identité européenne
depuis le xviiie siècle c'est-à-dire
pour la modernité la modernité
européenne est fondée sur cette utopie
sur ce monde idéalisé et celui de
l'antiquité et donc souffler pour le jeu
politique la dimension symbolique est
essentiel parce qu'ils ont construit les
ensembles sur la base des symboles donc
c'est un enjeu fondamental pour l'europe
du xviiie vous dis bien du 20e deux
jours doit être clair monsieur privé la
caisse quand vous dites que il y avait
une forme de romantisme quand olivier
toscer dit qu'une forme de romantisme en
fait chez les dirigeants français à
accueillir la grèce parce que cette
berceau de la démocratie parce que
démagogie démocratie ce sont des mots
grecs il ya
l'entente dans le documentaire sexé ont
construit un espace politique par ce
type de symbole
oui on a construit ses dires c'est la
construction européenne depuis le xviiie
siècle on joue avec ça avec un fondement
alors où ces tremblements entendu les
malentendus se trouve entre la
thématique européenne et l'état
il ya une dialectique extrêmement
complexes entre ces deux ensembles qui
bien sûr il faut le suivre dans
l'histoire et qui donne un résultat
particulier qui je pense est au centre
de la crise c'est que ces populations
qui ont construit ces peuples grecs qui
devaient être si vous voulez à l'image
de l'imaginaire européen il fallait
fabriquer des grecs ont ils été imaginé
par les européens mais de la matière
première
c'était des ottomans c'était deux
autoroutes là il ya eu un hiatus dès le
début vous êtes d'accord
mon raisonnement donc cette population
qui se trouve l'équipe qui est un
mélange de paysans aussi des gens des
léventins des gens très
astucieux etc voient la possibilité
d'une rente
on peut obtenir les soutiens des
européens l'argent de l'hérault pain en
vendant d'une certaine manière en
mettant en avant ses rôles qu'il a hélas
nous avons vraiment une situation une
structure fondamentale qui fait que
l'état grec jeudi l'état qu'avec pas les
autres respect si vous voulez de la
présence québec il ya les diasporas et
la marine marchande et à l'état grec est
un état rentier pour des raisons
géopolitiques économiques certes on est
ainsi par des raisons symboliques et ses
essais l'exagération de cette logique
des rentes
nous avons vécu pendant les quatre
dernières décennies et qui explosent
maintenant philippe dessertine vous êtes
d'accord on était dans du symbole dans
cet antre et moi j'étais vraiment
passionné par le documentaire d'olivier
pousseurs même si j'ai peut-être revenir
pour moi votre lecture est-ce aussi une
lecture romantique parce que justement à
mon sens vous êtes beaucoup trop dans
une vision idéalisée dans la réalité des
années 70 d'avoir ce qui est passionnant
et je crois que c'est vraiment important
pour les jeunes générations parce qu'il
faut pas oublier qu'aujourd'hui vous
avez plein de jeunes en europe qui n'ont
pas connu cette époque
et quand on voit un documentaire comme
ça on est surpris qu est ce qu on voit
des couleurs etc
on a l'impression que c'est le monde
d'aujourd'hui c'est pas si lointain que
ça c'est pas si lointain que ça quand on
parle de dictature en europe va se
rappeler là on a une séquence quand même
hein c'est à dire milieu des années 70
c'est là la mort de franco matt haig
l'espagne parce que vous avez cette
dimension là le portugal
ça a été aussi un pays en dictature ya
pas si longtemps et la grèce c'est un
pays qui sort de dictature aussi donc on
est on va dire dans un ensemble
politique on doit comprendre par rapport
à l'époque on est dans le moment où la
guerre froide et le plus tièdes 79 ça va
être l'afghanistan ça va être la sphère
polonaise
on est dans un moment de très fortes
tensions on doit comprendre que l'europe
à ce moment-là joue on va dire ces
cartes ces cartes par rapport on est
encore dans la construction de l'europe
de la paix post oui on va surtout dans
l'europe de la paix avec l'europe de la
guerre face à c'est à dire qu'à ce
moment là on rigole pas et vous êtes
dans un équilibre très compliqué avec
les états unis et je crois que là quand
on est en train d'évoquer et moi je
partage totalement ce que vous venez de
dire sur la réalité grecque mais on doit
comprendre que les européens les
allemands en particulier et les français
valéry giscard d'estaing à ce moment là
il a un interlocuteur privilégié c'est
le mood schmidt qui elles sont amies
finalement je dirais dans
quels ils vont avoir chacun un rôle
notamment dans ces questions
d'élargissement là à l'époque nous avons
la grèce qui est une carte absolument
fondamental vis-à-vis de la turquie et
la turquie on doit pas l'oublier la
turquie c'est évidemment un élément très
important dans la logique allemand de
l'époque c'est-à-dire l'immigration a
demandé du rck
mais attention la turquie est aussi la
deuxième grande base américaine en
europe et on doit avoir toujours ça dans
la déprime la turquie elle est dans
l'otan bien sûr c'est l'allié privilégié
et face calmement moi je fasse je suis
tout à fait heureux qu'on le dise parce
que le rapport à la turquie était été un
élément majeur de la relation avec la
grèce on pouvait pas négliger cet aspect
là donc c'est très important ce qui
s'est passé devant tout ce qui se passe
après dans la décennie et dans les
décennies suivantes ou notamment la
grande bretagne alliés des etats-unis
n'arrête pas de pousser pour
l'intégration de la turquie dans
l'europe et la vision est évidemment
qu'on les états unis depuis longtemps de
la turquie faut se rappeler un camp en
pleine crise en 65 jours d'huile à
l'intégration la sortie de l'europe
winants sauf que la turquie maintenant
elle est vraiment dans la frontière on
va dire la plus tendue de l'europe c'est
à dire c'est la frontière avec
évidemment le kurdistan qui fait partie
de l'attirail et surtout avec la syrie
et là lorsqu'on évoque la situation
d'aujourd'hui géopolitique c'est
absolument capital à comprendre honte à
dire qu'on est dans une logique qui
n'est pas du tout seulement économique
la grande erreur que l'on doit faire se
figurer qu' il n'y a que l'économie et
qu'une logique de dettes des deux
approches et vend donc là en fait on
nous vend une logique économique de la
grèce va sortir de l'europe et que ça va
être dramatique etc sauf que derrière la
question joaillier géopolitique vu le
territoire grec est complètement aller
c'est raté mais allez capitale alors
qu'elle est capital dans le réseau
demande actuelle alors benjamin coriat
oui non si je peux me permettre moi
aussi j'ai beaucoup apprécié le film
parce que pour la raison qui a été dit
hein parce qu'il remet en mémoire toute
une série d'événements et puis non
toujours à l'occasion des crises les
narratif se refont et le narratif qui
est fait aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout
celui qui annonce fine donc c'est très
important de confronter ses génératif
par contre alors là où je serai plus
réservés c'est quand vous parlez de
malentendus non je crois pas que
et un quelconque malentendu je suis
plutôt sur ce qui a été dit en tout cas
comme je le comprends sur des intérêts
bien compris et partagés c'est à dire
que d'un côté la grèce a bien saisi
l'opportunité du bénéfice à rentrer dans
l'espace européen
mais l'espace européen avait un grand
besoin d'intégrer ses frontières à
l'intérieur même de son espace quelles
qualités là quel était l'intérêt de
quand vous dites il y avait un intérêt à
intégrer dans ses frontières cet espace
est double il ya un intérêt géopolitique
on la ronde a longuement insisté
par rapport à la turquie etc il ya un
intérêt en termes de désir d'europe si
je peux dire qu'ils dont on aimerait
bien que ça revienne un par parenthèse
en l'occurrence l'europe prend sous son
aile des pays qui sortent de la
dictature et héberge des démocraties et
en plus est il faut le dire
généreuse avec ses démocraties parce que
il ya eu des fonds structurels
extrêmement abondante oui solide oui à
l'europe a plus du tout fait ça depuis
un essai quand même des mal très mal
oui mais comme elle l'a fait presque
sans fonds structurels d'unification
je vous en prie terminé donc je finis
voilà donc cessé un intérêt bien compris
de part et d'autre c'est pas du tout un
malentendu alors il se trouve que on y
reviendra
les choses ont évolué de telle manière
qu à un certain moment les choses se
sont retendus si je peux dire mais
pendant longtemps chacun il ya largement
régler son compte à l'ats olivier toscer
est passé non c'est ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il ya un malentendu une
certaine façon parce qu'on part
géopolitique mais là l'europe à l'époque
la cec de l'économie c'est un espace un
marché unique donc encore dans l'esprit
des fondateurs il ya beaucoup plus que
ça on a commencé par l'économie et on a
rendu les intérêts économiques fondu
pour créer une base mais l'idée c'est
quand même construire la paix
reconstruire l'europe et s'est fait
quelque part dans une dernière chose
c'est que c'est que deuxième chose je ne
se cachent pas tout à fait d'avoir une
roue c'est que l'europe était généreuse
la grèce sortait du régime
une des têtes sur des colonels ce qui
est heureusement
c'est une pensée généreuse de ces de
consolider la démocratie en grèce mais
elle a été plus généreuse avec les grecs
avec les portugais et les espagnols par
exemple parce que c'est ça mais pour
complice de temps c'est possible alors
on va pas faire ici le débat sur ce qui
a été distribué par don à la grèce au
portugal pascal durand brault d'abord
pour pour arbitrer c'est je me permets
de robert schuman disait justement
construire au départ de la construction
d'europe c'était construire des
solidarités de fait c'est à dire que à
destiner à donc en fait il y avait
effectivement la proche qui était une
approche économique mais en réalité il y
avait de la nécessité est d'essayer de
relier aussi des êtres humains ce qui
était d'ailleurs la phrase de jean
monnet mais moi je distingue quand même
deux époques un peu différente dans le
documentaire je crois que ça a été bien
montré et je crois qu'il ya une logique
pour répondre si votre question pourquoi
il ya l'époque où effectivement sorti de
la dictature et cetera le côté idéaliste
berceau de la démocratie et et puis
problèmes de la turquie fights et hop on
rentre la grèce ça c'est la première
étape
et j'allais dire que cette étape elle et
elle est presque elle découle
d'elle-même elle est naturelle analyse
ces têtes en france il est très proche
de giscard d'estaing qui vient d'être
élu qui veut comme toujours marquer la
présence française sur la zone sur le
monde
tout ça est cohérent il ya une deuxième
phase est celle là elle est beaucoup
plus intéressante sur un plan à la fois
économiques et politiques c'est la phase
effectivement rentré de l'euro
financement crédit etc
mais ça moi lorsque on va y revenir vers
est sûr mais ce que ce que ce qu'on ne
peut pas perdre idée c'est que la notion
de marché unique
il a besoin de croissance marche et
notamment l'allemagne et aimer la france
aussi un as besoin d'exporter à
l'intérieur de la zone euro et autres
fallait élargir le marché aime bien sûr
et on va financer la grèce à tour de
bras
parce que le déficit c'est un nouveau
marché et comment on fait de la
croissance bidon c'est à dire comment on
invente un phénomène qui n'existe plus
qu'ils essayent de la croissance et
comment on le finance que l'on est bien
ça c'en est une illustration
on a la même en espagne avec moi
immobiliers ont fait les ongles ont créé
des finances ont créé des bulles et
après tout s'effondre les charges et
reviendra bien sûr on
invoquer tellement des questions je sais
pas quoi terrible moi je vais je vais
lancer une idée c'est que j'ai expliqué
si vous voulez les facteurs structurels
dans l'histoire de la grèce moderne
c'est à dire de l'état grec le de la
rente qui vient de cette fonction il ya
bien sûr sous l'ailé dimension
géopolitique géostratégique qui donne
aussi de la rentrée la grèce a obtenu de
la rente c'est à dire de l'argent qui ne
venaient pas de sa propre production et
30 milliards ça rentre ça c'est quand
même nom mais dès le 19e siècle
grâce donc à son rôle symbolique n'est
pas du romantisme dans l'essence de
quelque chose d'unique et il sait itil
on a besoin de cette référence
identitaire en europe
et deuxièmement et donc elle est la c30
ça c'est un phénomène qui a des hauts et
des bas dans dans l'histoire du rock
ensuite qu'est ce qui se passe on entre
en europe sous caramanlis carrément les
soins dire c'est vraiment un européen
qui puisse vraiment voir la grèce comme
un composant de l'europe mais ensuite il
ya papandréou qui arrivent au pouvoir
ils peuvent pas nous avait annoncé qu'il
se retirait la grèce de leurs attendrait
au terme d un dress code révisé et
communautés européennes le même syndicat
la même mafia c'était son slogan main
alors en intrants il fait chanter les
robes pour obtenir justement les fonds
structurels donc la logique de la rente
s'installe à nouveau et nous avons une
période pendant laquelle tout on
s'organise autour des raisons de la
rente est ensuite l'entrée dans
l'hérault donne encore une possibilité
et ça va d'avril en train de me dire que
les grecs en fait sont des rentiers
c'est peut-être contre les blancs
appréciant le grec ont été piégés dans
leur antre parce que cette générosité
c'est le poison mais sur celle le
pharmakon qui devient un poison c'est le
médicament mais un poison c'est un
poison pour nous on a été empoisonné par
cet argent oui parce que vous êtes aussi
laisser empoisonner pardon oui mais
enfin oui bien sûr
il faut redescendre c'est pas bien c'est
cet argent nous a fait du bien parce que
cet argent a détruit toute capacité de
vivre grâce à sion dont la production
est maintenant que l'argent ne vient pas
nous sommes incapables de nous en sortir
alors maintenant je voudrais revenir je
vous rappelle vraiment assez c'est
extrêmement important à bien comprendre
le contexte parce que tout à l'heure je
l'évoqué 79 l'aghanistan
ça c'est des choses on a complètement
oublié 80 c'est la pologne
c'est à dire c'est le moment où en
europe d'un coup tout le monde commence
à trembler d'ailleurs on se demande mais
on va où exactement vous avez rigal
je suis du bloc communiste vous avez
envie on n'est pas du tout dans la chute
là on est dans le moment où l'europe se
dit où vont s'arrêter les chars les
reagan qui vient d'être élue aux états
unis vous avez la révolution iranienne
79 vous avez le deuxième choc pétrolier
c'est à dire qu'on est dans un état qui
on doit bien souvenir de ça c'est pour
ça que le romantisme de trucs ça on peut
vous raconter tout ce qu'on veut après
coup on était tout sauf le romantisme à
ce moment là on était au contraire dans
la région j'ai aussi réagi dans la
realpolitik et l'europe est à mon sens
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut dire
parce que c'est pas évidemment à ce
moment là on le disait peut-être pas
dans la une des journaux mais avait une
politique très claire à l'époque sur la
méditerranée en disant on doit avoir une
logique de barrage par rapport à un
risque réel que l'on voit monter à l'est
on était dans cette logique là donc ça
c'est extrêmement important par rapport
à ce qu ont évoqué moi je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec l'idée d'une sorte de
bulle comme ça tombait alors l'europe
qu'est ce qu'elle fait est finances
avant tout l'armée grecque je crois
qu'il faut être bien on a on va voir on
va vendre l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles on va avoir une acceptation
va fermer les yeux sur tout un tas de
modes de fonctionnement de la société
grecque
c'est que derrière notamment l'industrie
de l'armement française allemande ça
mais exporte enfin enrichi c'est un gros
mais qu'est ce que je veux dire c'est
les bons et les méchants ils sont ou
alors qu'on n'est pas là on est jamie
c'est le deuxième budget militaire au
monde après les états unis n'ont quand
même pas faut pas que ça irait là c'est
en pourcentage depuis les quais non
non mais je voudrais bien chiffres clés
pourtant je voulais juste rappeler
jusqu'à 2011
la grèce a été entre le troisième et le
cinquième importateur d'armes
conventionnelles du monde
non vous vous entendez bien à un moment
donné on a un numéro à la chine 1
milliard 300 millions d'habitants numéro
2 l'inde n'est pas le hasard un milliard
cent millions d'habitants numéro 3 la
grèce 11 millions d'habitants
et ça c'est l'industrie allemande
l'industrie française l'industrie
américaine donc on peut dire ce qu'on
veut sur le fait que l'europe ne savait
pas ce rendez pas compte tout ça c'est
de la rigolade
tout le monde le savait parfaitement
simplement évidemment il ya des choses
qu'on ne pouvait pas dire officiellement
alors justement le temps de ranger si on
part donc toute trouvée je voudrais
qu'on réécoute jean arthuis qui qui
avait une vision quelque peu au moins
claires et nettes de ce qui était en
train de se jouer
une sorte d'allégresse qui faisaient que
c'était bien vu d'admettre la grèce
parce que j'ai été le berceau de la
démocratie
là on parle pas des vocations parle de
finances d'économies bien sûr bien sûr
mais il faut que l'art de gouverner et
s'accommode de la réalité or trop
souvent la gouvernance publique
manille prend appui sur le déni de
réalité elle est absolument incroyable
cette dernière phrase de jean arthuis
donc pour revenir là ce qui nous
intéresse on s'est appuyé la gouvernance
s'appuie sur le déni de réalité donc on
n'a pas voulu voir non plus les
problématiques qu'ils allaient se poser
vous nous parliez tout à l'heure de ce
budget militaire en fin de de ce que ça
laissait supposer mais dans l'autre sens
on n'a pas en face en face de ces 30
milliards qu'on pouvait donner par an
mais entre guillemets mis en place un
véritable système d'état sachant que
j'étais ambitieuse mais je vais me
répéter je suis assez d'accord avec avec
deux serties c'est vraiment la question
des mares hâtif
c'est à dire que on est aujourd'hui en
train de fabriquer une histoire suivant
laquelle on s'est pas rendu compte
on a été berné par la grèce mais c'est
pas du tout ça l'histoire c'est pas du
tout ça et je crois et je crois que de
certina remis sur la table toute une
série d'éléments s
fiel sur pourquoi on avait besoin de la
grèce pourquoi on a favorisé son
armement non seulement du point de vue
des intérêts des deux mondes
franco-allemand si je peux dire voilà
des armes wallon mais aussi d'un point
de vue géopolitique et puis il faut
rajouter un troisième mot parce que ça
va nous être utiles dans le débat par la
suite
7 comment dire sur croissance du secteur
de l'armement grec qui évidemment est un
problème je suis pas du tout en train de
dire de ça elle a aussi une autre raison
est la raison qu'elle a c'est une des
défaillances de la construction
européenne ça veut dire que quand les
turcs ont débarqué à chypre l'europe a
totalement laissé faire a été totalement
incapable de gérer cette crise et donc
les les grecs se sont trouvés tout seul
en face à face à devoir gérer ce
problème et je dis pas ça pour rien je
dis ça parce que cette défaillance dans
la construction européenne on va la
trouver un autre niveau un peu plus tard
dans la construction de l'euro est tout
cet argent qui est arrivé en grèce d'où
il vient
des banquiers privés il faut quand même
rappeler que seuls les banquiers privés
peuvent acheter de la dette publique
dans cette période là et donc comment
dire la responsabilité de la finance
privée internationale qui a acheté toute
cette dette publique qui aujourd'hui
revient en boomerang c'est pas je veux
dire il ya une responsabilité des grecs
si on peut dire mais dans la mesure où
la finance internationale faisait les
mêmes taux d'intérêt quasiment à la
grèce que à l'allemagne on voit pas
pourquoi ils n'auraient pas utilisé
d'ailleurs en défense de la grèce c'est
mon dernier mot ils ont quand même cru à
4% par an pendant la décennie c'est à
dire nettement au-dessus de la moyenne
européenne alors je ne dis pas que tout
ça était bien mais je veux dire il ya
une finance qui a une grosse
responsabilité sur la formation de la
dette
alors justement on va revenir sur ce que
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure en début de
débat la question de l'entrée dans la
zone euro parce qu'on a fait entrer la
grèce et on sait maintenant pour toi et
quelques années plus tard on renégocie
cette fois ci pour entrer dans la zone
euro est ce que là on est dans le même
romantisme ou pas est-ce qu'on est dans
les mêmes dans le temps dans la même
dans le même contexte il semblerait que
non mais en attendant il s'avère que on
est toujours avec un état qui n'a pas de
cadastre qui n'est pas en capacité de
lever l'impôt et namas les
infrastructures il ya quelques mois sans
faute tout le monde s'en fout et que moi
c'est ça que j'aimerais moi je fais moi
j'entends que tout ce qui est dit je
crois qu'on est à peu près tous d'accord
sur l'analyse il ya un point ce qu'elle
moi je parce que ça m'a marqué dans le
documentaire
parce que là dessus c'est très très
clair c'est à dire que oui il ya des du
financement des banques privées etc
mais il ya un moment où on a conscience
de la réalité des comptes plus ou moins
trafic et de et donc on voit très bien
là parce que c'est là où il ya j'allais
dire une zone de non droit à la fois des
politiques est à la fois des juristes
c'est que on a fait semblant de regarder
ailleurs et quand monsieur arthuis dit
un déni de réalité
je suis désolé et pourtant je partage
beaucoup de ce qu'il dit dans ce
documentaire
mais là il se trompe ça n'est pas un
déni de réalité c'est qu'il ya eu une
volonté politique de regarder ailleurs
il ya une volonté politique de laisser
rentrer la grèce dans la zone euro avec
des chiffres qui étaient trafiqués mais
pourquoi quel intérêt à manuela même
jour les mêmes raisons excusez moi mais
juste quand même il sait quelque chose
qu'il faut préciser hélas nos
téléspectateurs peuvent aller sur
internet
retrouvez toutes ces informations la
grèce paie vous m'entendez bien en 2011
c'est à dire au moment où nous sommes
déjà au coeur de la crise la plus grave
qu'elle est mariée elle paie rubis sur
l'ongle des sous marins d'attaqué 1
attaque on est en grèce et sous marins
d'attaqué livré par l'allemagne
lp des hélicoptères chasseurs de chats
ne devraient pas la france pour est à
dire qu'on pourrait faire en donne de
l'euro pour pouvoir acheter des armes
mais attendez vous à bien comprendre
tout ça n'est pas choquant en soi si la
l'europe à une politique politique
extérieure dans une zone de plus en plus
tendue de plus en plus dangereuse qui ne
l'a jamais été autant qu'aujourd'hui
donc ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on
peut contester ou dire c'était de la
folie
l'europe très bien avoir cette stratégie
est simplement un moment donné faut dire
les choses complètement
m il faut garder pardon messieurs mais
est ce que c'est à la grèce de porter la
sécurité et la défense européenne fins
morceaux et l'échangent contre une si on
est ramené à mes failles à partir d'un
moment on est ramené à mes failles dans
la construction européenne
parce qu'à partir du moment où il n'y a
pas de politique de défense commune pour
des pour des tas de raisons
on est obligé de la faire de manière
latérale si je peux dire est donc
d'assigner à un certain nombre de pays
en l'occurrence la france l'angleterre
et localement à la grèce des fonctions
de défense qu'on peut pas assumer
centralement donc je veux dire il faut
dessiller les yeux des gens et dire la
vérité est un phénomène qui est très
grave je ne juge insiste sur ce point
c'est un peu comme si on voulait sauver
l'industrie automobile française par
exemple est content ce qui ne serait pas
un choix c'est choquant et qu'on prête à
toutes les personnes de l'argent pour
pouvoir acheter une voiture neuve pour
que la production repart pas loin on l'a
fait souvent on l'avait surnommé je
dirais imaginons va et donc les banques
prêtent à tout le monde sans regarder la
capacité des gens à pouvoir ou pas
remboursé derrière leur automobile ou
même à l'entretenir payer l'assurance et
payer l'essence est en fait ce qui s'est
passé là c'est exactement ça c'est que
pour que nos industries pour une grande
part puisse continuer aussi à produire
après on peut discuter est ce que c'est
bien pas bien ça c'est un débat moral
mais pour qu'elle puisse le faire on m'a
prêté et notamment nos banques avec les
garanties de l'état derrière parce que
c'est ça qui s'est passé elles ont
continué à prêter sans même s'interroger
et comme certains ont commencé à pointer
du doigt en disant mais attention on
prête beaucoup trop à la grèce c'est pas
possible il ya ils ont eu 90 euros rien
donc 2004 par exemple qui a pointé mons
a pointé et là on leur dit mais là on
l'a regardé ailleurs sait rien on va
arranger les comptes et puis on prend
des auditeurs qui vont être
je voudrais tirer une conclusion d'un
point de vue grecque
qu'est ce que nous sommes et ce que nous
sommes les victimes de l'erreur alors
vous pouvez avoir deux discours l'un dix
courses et nous sommes les victimes
parce que là où ne nous apporte pas
suffisamment des de la solidarité etc
c'est un peu le discours du système
politique grecque
que ce soit la droite que ce soit le
parti socialiste est évidemment syriza
ils disent la même chose sauf qu'ils
n'ont aucune responsabilité sur ce qui
se passe je parle de bus secours
attendaient il ya un autre discours et
l'autre discours c'est que pour rendre
service pour accomplir des tâches
européenne la défense européenne
l'identité européenne qu'est ce qui
s'est passé eh bien vous nous avez donné
de l'argent et c'est par jean nous
empoisonner
il a détruit notre société il a détruit
notre capacité de production mais il a
construit des routes des routes qui
mènent ainsi vous avez parlé de
croissance et notre croissance était
pour la consommation interne
les fameuses routes qui ont aidé les
oligarques de faire fortune à travers la
corruption sont des autoroutes pour les
grecs pour aller dans leur maison
secondaire
ce n'est pas pour l'investissement
absolument rien en ce sens moi je mets
en a mais je me situe aussi dans une
critique envers les roms eux mais dans
l'autre sens un rapport au discours
principal c'est vrai que je ne m'inscris
pas dans une logique de rente mais je ne
m'inscris pas dans une logique de
parasitisme et parce que je les
considère également que les grecs sont
incapables de produire des richesses
eux-mêmes et qu'ils doivent rester dans
une sorte de dépendance par rapport à
l'europe voilà ce qui est intéressant
c'est sûr il ya eu cette rente mais
l'appareil productif grec finalement ne
sait absolument pas développé on est
toujours sur un peu d'agriculture
non non river on avait en avait un
appareil productif avant d'entrer on
avait un glaive et détruit par une
détruit la rampe par l'apa par là où est
ce qu'on va travailler investir quand on
veut avoir des professions de service
qui gère la rampe mais je voudrais juste
après à porter un autre élément mais
juste quand même on a tous les deux
l'âge d'avoir connu avant malgré tout il
ya eu une amélioration on va dire de la
qualité de vie de la population car par
allongement de ce qu'on a vu
voyez je crois que c'est important aussi
quand même que la jeunesse en tant que
ça que la jeunesse de romero et
maintenant on le paye d'accord on est
d'accord il ya un retour mais qui est
quand même pas du tout le retour en
arrière au moment de la fin des
dictatures des colonnes alors je dis
regardez l'âge moyen de voir quand même
pas je crois mais après ce temps mais
justement par rapport à ce que nous
sommes en train de dire je crois qu'on
doit avoir conscience de sacs la
géopolitique en ce moment l'europe doit
l'intégrer les citoyens européens
doivent comprendre ce qui se passe
arrêter d'avoir des jugements à
l'entente depuis à l'emporte-pièce lâche
on les y en a marre ce sont des
paresseux sais je sais pas quoi qu'ils
sont là des ferments dramatique de
choses qui peuvent se passer en europe
et qu'on a connu dans le passé
la grèce a joué un rôle géopolitique
pour les européens c'est absolument
clair elle le joue encore aujourd'hui au
moment où je le répète nous avons le
conflit syrien et dash qui est à la
porte de la galerie la grèce aujourd'hui
c'est le désert des tartares 1 2
c'est à dire c'est le dernier rempart de
la grèce delà de l'europe avant le
l'endroit où commence toutes les guerres
mais n'oublions pas que nous avons
exactement le même phénomène qui va se
produire bientôt ça va être avec la
question ukrainienne où l'europe va
devoir dire on écrase la dette
ukrainienne parce que nous ne voulons
pas aller mourir à kiev
mais qui va falloir que les gens meurent
sur cette frontière là nous en sommes là
aujourd'hui
hélas la grèce comme l'ukraine pauses
toutes les deux un problème en apparence
économique qui est en géopolitique et
rapidement
non non j il ya tout ce qu'on a dit
j'ai souscrit assez largement sur la
dimension géopolitique sur la rente bien
entendu il ya des dimensions de rente
mais il ya aussi des éléments on va dire
plus trivialement économique et à partir
du moment où on impose un taux de change
fixe entre la grèce et l'allemagne et
plus généralement la grèce et
l'allemagne du nord est ce que vous
voulez dire par taux de change fixe à
l'euro en europe l'euro voilà qui est
donc totalement sous-évalué pour
l'allemagne et les pays du nord est
totalement surévalué pour la grèce et
les pays du sud n'ont la pause pancréas
et lequel ils veulent cesser les
enseignants attendent et on a construit
l'europe en principe avec une série de
mécanismes d'ajustement en espérant que
tout le monde allait converger donc
c'est à partir du moment où on constate
qu'on ne convergent pas deux choses
premièrement ça explique en partie la
désindustrialisation dont vous parlez
c'est pas seulement que les gens se sont
arc boutés sur la route c'est que tout
simplement ils pouvaient pas tenir une
en termes de compétitivité relative
bon d'un côté et de l'autre côté les
pays qui ont bénéficié de ce taux de
change doivent admettre qu'ils doivent
faire des contreparties à un moment et
là on y est la question c'est veux-t-on
garder l'europe et qu'il faut installer
des contreparties pour permettre aux
pays en retard de radio entre dans un
processus vertueux sinon faut faire
sauter le monde ne peut pas avoir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre
il est sérieux là c'est pas possible moi
je suis assez curieusement encore en
grande partie avec lauriane m'épate pas
complètement je pense que l'europe
depuis le départ on doit en avoir
conscience est là encore si une
pédagogie qu'on doit faire vis-à-vis des
jeunes générations
l'europe par principe et l'association
de gens riches et de gens moins riches
et leurs principes depuis le début et
depuis le début ça fonctionne comment
avec une idée de transfert c'est à dire
pour que ça marche pour que les cils si
vous ouvrez les frontières et que vous
avez des gens pauvres d'un côté des gens
riches de l'autre c'est clair vous avez
immédiatement une migration
si vous avez s'il n'aura pas réussi à
fonctionner à s'ouvrir y compris avec
l'espagne qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
le portugal dans le milieu des années 70
c'est parce que tout de suite ya une
politique de transferts qui doit la fête
et l'énorme erreur de des deux grands
pays que sont la france et l'allemagne à
partir de 2003 2004 pour des raisons
qui sont pas les mêmes c'est d'avoir
dire on n'a plus besoin de faire de
transfert ils ont maintenant un taux bas
et donc on laisse les gens s'endetter et
donc par conséquent là on s'en lave les
mains et aujourd'hui on est en train
d'en payer les dividendes rapide
transfert est absolument car j'étais
déjà un économiste renommé ça parce que
ce n'est pas une question de des riches
et des pauvres c'est une question de
pays organisé et des pays en difficultés
d'organisation s'est on a besoin les
transferts dont avait besoin de la grèce
mais c'est très délicat
c'est pas de l'argent c'est de
l'organisation et sa de construire un
état ces deux leaders nous aidez nous
aidez des protégés si vous voulez les
éléments sein de la société par rapport
à la concurrence des opportunistes enfin
de deux ans nous avons été enfin les
éléments sein de la société grecque ont
été marginalisés la classe politique
qu'on accuse
c'est pas la classe politique y est
d'origine c'est la classe politique qui
est le résultat d'une sélection négative
parce que les règles du g et les
contextes qui a été créée par l'europe à
cause de la rente à effacer tout ce qui
était le mieux donc c'est pas on n'a pas
vraiment on n'a pas besoin d'argent la
grèce est un pays potentiellement très
riches parce que nous avons des
avantages comparatifs
comme aucun pays au monde c'est vrai là
mais jamais non attendez nous allons
vous ouvriez allergies liées
je termine vous oubliez que ce n'est pas
seulement la grèce les territoires
grecque mais c'est aussi la première
marine marchande au monde et la diaspora
si les éléments ne sont pas du tout
coordonné l'escale du rabbin germain
corium a pointé du doigt et ça a été dit
également tout à l'heure le défaut
européens par rapport à une défense
commune par rapport à une capacité que
ce sera moi je voudrais qu'on pointe
aussi le défaut parce que moi je suis
pas sur lala l'espèce de main invisible
qui voudraient le mal pour la grèce qui
voudraient le mal pour le rock etc
mais en revanche la houle a eu un
déficit majeur c'est que l'europe à un
moment s'est mise à raisonner uniquement
en termes financiers et on l'a dit les
banques privées ont un certain nombre
d'éléments de grands
entreprises qui ont pris la main
globalement d'euros le déficit que l'on
a c'est que on parlait des pères
fondateurs mais il y avait des
gouvernants entre guillemets politiques
qui étaient à la manoeuvre on en pense
ce qu'on veut on est d'accord on n'est
pas d'accord il y avait des débats là ce
qui se passe c'est que la zone euro
telle qu'elle a été mise en place telle
qu'elle fonctionne elle n'est
politiquement arbitré par aucune
instance démocratique oui le parlement
recettes ne dit rien les la construction
oui mais c'est pas grave bien sûr parce
que qui est en capacité à un moment
d'arbitrer entre la finance l'économie
qui est là bas une entité politique de
l'état dans des réformes structurelles
et on n'a pas demandé à la grèce au
départ au départ on lui a pas demandé
une réforme fiscale importante
ça s'est passé complètement on lui a dit
baisse des dépenses et baisse son budget
on a on n'est pas rentré dans les
réformes structurelles parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu de volonté politique là non plus
tu essayé d'aborder la question
autrement que sous l'angle finances
alors justement là on va essayer de se
poser un petit peu sur ce qui se passe
en ce moment on est à cinq mois de
négociations entre le gouvernement
syriza alexis tsipras ce et la troïka
dire maintenant les estime des
institutions puisqu'il pression de
l'appeler comme ça c'est le
politiquement correct alors on voit que
en l'espèce depuis 2009 depuis le début
de la crise il ya eu plusieurs plans
d'austérité successifs qu'on a des
chiffres catastrophiques en terme de
chômage on est à quasi on est à 25% sa
seconde saison chez les jeunes 43 %
d'augmentation du taux de mortalité
infantile fin c'est absolument
catastrophique et un retour arrière en
termes d'évolution les chiffres qui ce
qui est absolument dingue dsk dominique
strauss kahn intervient sur twitter la
semaine dernière en plein pic en plein
en pleine dramaturgie pour dire
apprenons de nos erreurs et prône un une
manière d pas une d'un étalement enfin
une renégociation claire de la dette
certains demandent carrément à l'annuler
comme ce qu'on a pu faire en 53 avec
l'allemagne est ce que c'est possible
d'annuler une dette comme celle ci
philippe dessertine
non mais attendez d'abord c'est déjà ce
qu'on fait dans les faits on a repoussé
un maturité la grèce à une mathieu a une
dette de maturité moyenne de plus de 15
ans la france acceptant donc en réalité
aujourd'hui on
on voit bien que la situation est
intenable du point de vue financier et
donc pour le moment on repousse on
repousse on le dit pas mais on est déjà
dans de la restructuration
ce que propose dominique strauss kahn à
mon avis est redoutable
parce que c'est de dire bon alors on
efface mais du coup on amène plus rien
or je ne crois pas que ce soit la bonne
solution
je crois que la vraie solution qu'on a
évoqué sans cesse ce que en fait la
raison sur laquelle on est en train de
de tourner sans cesse ses dires le
problème et pas l'austérité comme on le
dit tout le temps
le problème c'est la dette et l'europe
en doute la de la dette non c'est même
pas ça le poids la date on sait qu'il
est intenable mais c'est la question de
dire est-ce que vous avez une économie
qui ne va pas fonctionner que sur de la
dette que sur la dette et quand vous
disiez la rente c'est à dire de la
dépense publique qui alimentent
l'économie c'est ça le problème est donc
là pour arriver à changer vraiment
complètement
on va dire le logiciel économique de la
grèce c'est des investissements massifs
c'est pas des investissements publics
des investissements privés là je pense
que ce sera pas d'accord mais c'est des
investissements privés qu'il doit venir
immédiatement l'infrastructure les
routes etc
c'est plus ça le problème c'est de là
donc là et maintenant battre autant va
dire ah ben on vous rend en bourse où on
joue on ne parle plus de dettes mais
attention je n'ai plus rien hélas non
c'est pas la solution parce que
l'économie grecque aujourd'hui on n'est
pas capable de repartir
benjamin de deux choses là où je diverge
avec de certines les choses reviennent à
la normale
il ya un problème de dette bien sûr
qu'il ya un problème est même si la
maturité de la dette grecque est plus
longue
c'est à dire que parce que ce que vous
avez dit sa tombe
et ça tombe drue vous savez comme moi
que la grèce d'ici fin août doit payer
15 milliards entre principe à ouidah
cornes élevé qu il n avait pas eu la
dague pour le moment lui donne pas comme
vous avez constaté et sur les sur les 7
milliards
on devait donner en a pas donné un
centime sur l on a fait perdre six mois
bien bon donc on ne lui donne pas un
soyons très bon on ne lui donne pas
qu'on lui donne pas été un pionnier fois
donc il ya ça tombe dru sommes donc dru
donc il faut pas croire qu'il n'y a pas
de problème de dette
1 après il ya deux questions il ya une
question purement conjoncturelle qui est
qu'on ne peut pas continuer avec ces
politiques d'austérité dont on sait les
résultats qu'elles ont produit depuis
cinq ans le fmi n'a rien appris l'europe
n'a rien
a pris ses méthodes il ya deux ans je
suis et qu'ils avaient été trop loin
voilà exactement après avoir admis qu'il
s'était trompé là ils ont totalement
oublié qu'ils ont dit qu'ils s'étaient
trompés ils veulent refaire la même
chose donc syriza est parfaitement fondé
à dire il faut un volet relance pour un
volet urgences sanitaires etc
après il ya le problème de plus long
terme alors on peut discuter sur la
discussion sur la proposition de strauss
kahn
c'est peut-être pas forcément la
meilleure mais tout le monde sait qu'il
va falloir remettre la question de la
dette sur la table et il faut pas faire
peur aux téléspectateurs ont fait ça
sans arrêt éponger des dettes les
téléspectateurs saft il que 35 milliards
de dette irakienne ont été épongés en un
quart d'heure après que le bouche soir
en mairie à bagdad
bon on a pas on a fait zéro histoire ça
a été totalement placé 320 oui non mais
ça on verra on verra
trop de fautes c'est le temps dont bwin
non mais on arrive je ne dis pas qu'il
faut l'épongé totalement mais il faut
l'aborder aussi et ça l'union européenne
jusqu'à présent s'y refuse on reste on
revient à la case de départ encore les
discussions de l'économie le problème
est politique et économie est ce qu on a
transformé lors le fonctionnement de
l'état grec a faim les investisseurs
suisses venir à toi il ya trois choses à
faire oui c'est simple mais
politiquement très difficile oui c'est
d'abord rhésus this we deuxième la
simplification de l'administration
troisième la stabilisation des
conditions d'imposition est ensuite
l'investissement va venir de manière
massive et on aura 7 % de croissance à 0
en déplacement en europe car ce moment
on arrive on a besoin et ça a été dit
d'un grand plan d'investissements moi je
n'ai pas de divergences sur le fait
qu'il faut également des investissements
privés c'est une évidence si on a su
garantir on a su garantir les banques le
risque des banques et on a repris la
dette et je ne vais pas contester mais
on a repris la dette à titres publics
il faut maintenant que l'europe fasse
effectivement d euros band c'est à dire
en gros quel elle fasse des des
applications de manière à rendre l'aude
a globalement l'europe
il faut qu'on ait une gouvernance
politique également des investissements
que l'europe soit sur des
investissements du futur et qu'on arrête
uniquement des dessus les
infrastructures qui ne profite qu'à
quelques grands genres peuvent hélas
keshi désolé malheureux alors qu'on
avait la question fera l'objet m
messieurs se fera l'objet pascal durand
s'il vous plaît je vais sévir par ce
sera l'objet d'un autre débat merci
beaucoup on a essayé de déblayer pour
tout ça on voit bien que chauffeur la
question de la grèce en fait ne peut pas
se détacher de la question de la
construction européenne
merci à vous d'avoir participé à ce
débat nous avoir éclairé
rendez vous la semaine prochaine avec
claire barsacq pour un débat sur les
monnaies locales rien à voir mais c'est
comme ça nous on se retrouve très vite
vous pouvez bien entendu réagir sur
notre adresse internet a bien rome
au fond